so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your host KL SM and
today we're talking about The Great
Train Robbery most infamous heist in
British history and as with all of our
videos this one is based on original
script submitted To Us by a member of
our writing team this one being Radu
Alexander follow them at their socials
below which will be alongside my own but
let's get to
it you won't believe this but they've
stolen on a train that was the special
announcement heard on Police radios in
the early hours of August 8th 1963 after
a gang of criminals pulled off one of if
not the most infamous and audacious
heists in British history they robbed a
Royal Male train heading from Glasgow to
London and made off with about 120 mail
bags containing some 2.6 million about
£60 million in today's money nobody was
killed although one train driver did
receive a serious C on the Noggin and
the author of this one has has decided
to include several but not too many
britishisms so I'm going to correct that
by just adding my own as of when I feel
like it you brought this on yourself I'm
going to do it I talk like a common
northerner I'm going to own it CAU on
the noggin that however was only the
beginning of our little tale at times
the story played out like a classic
Caper movie full of mysterious and Shady
characters precise actions and daring
prison escapes then there were the times
it seemed more like a comedy where the
bumbling criminals behave more like a
Monty Python tribute act this included
moments such as recruiting a train
driver who couldn't drive a train and
leaving behind fingerprints evidence on
a Monopoly board throughout the entire
Saga the media covered every single tiny
aspect of the story at times portraying
the gang as the most cunning criminals
to ever set foot in England and other
times a bunch of lovable rap scallions
and who did they hurt really except for
all the people that they hurt by hitting
them on the head get them old like you
know tap on the swed and the public
absolutely ate that all up becoming
utterly fascinated with this crime and
it's no wonder then that this house
became immortalized in British criminal
law as The Great Train
Robbery so our Story begins in early
1963 with a man named Gordon goody a
regular member of London's criminal
underground in fact he had just been
quitt of robbery when he got a message
to stop by the office of a solic clerk
named Brian field for a little chap he
and the fellow gang member named Buster
Edwards headed there where the field
introduced them to a mysterious man only
as the olster man this Shady character
had informed them about a big score and
was looking for someone who might be
interested in it Brian field who
regularly passed on some tips to his
more shall we say unsavory clients
thought that goody and his crew were
just the guys they were searching for
the sterman had valuable info about the
Royal Male including the schedule on
routs that the male trains and which
ones will be carrying a lot of money
aboard specific ically he knew that the
August 8th overnight from Glasgow to
London would be transporting millions of
pounds in its high value package coach
known as the hvp for a habitual robber
like goody this kind of information was
like a drug he could just not resist it
and once he heard about it there wasn't
any doubt in his mind that he would try
to rob it he just needed to get together
a crew to carry out the heist of the
century goodi and Edwards were already
part of the criminal group the Southwest
gang but it wasn't nearly big enough for
the kind of score they had in mind so he
started recruiting and recruiting they
did so now we're not really going to
mention everyone who was involved with
the heist because it would just be me
listing 15 separate names so I'm just
going to stick with the main characters
of the story for now so we already have
Gordon goody and Buster Edwards there
was also Charlie Wilson another member
of the Southwest gang who played the
role of the treasurer during the heist
and gave everyone their share of the
winnings I the most important criminal
involved in the robbery was Bruce
Reynolds another fellow gang member who
acted as The Mastermind and even earned
himself the not impressive nickname of
Napoleon for his role in the Caper and
we should also mention Ronnie bigs since
he also became the most well-known
person involved in The Great Train
Robbery even though his actual role in
The Heist was shockingly minor bigs
another career criminal was looking to
borrow some money and he approached
Reynolds whom he befriended in prison
instead of alone Reynolds let him in on
the heist and gave bigs the assignment
of finding a train driver who could
drive the locomotive once he was under
their control and presumably bigs was
thinking at this point well that's a
piece of piss and he recruited a train
driver known only under the pseudoname
stanner gates who turned out to be
completely useless but more on that
later because it really is quite funny
for now let's just say that Reynold had
assembled his crew of dastardly
delinquents and worked out a plan for
the robbery basically the idea was to
just rig a signal light to get the train
to stop hop aboard immobilize everyone
that needed immobilizing decouple the
engine and HPV coach from the rest of
the Train drive it further along the
track for some peace and quiet unload
all the money bags into trucks and speed
off into the night simple right well not
so
much so it was 6:50 p.m. on the night of
August 7th 1963 in the male train left
Glasgow and headed towards the Houston
Station in London the train was what's
known as a traveling post office or TP
which basically means Royal Mail
employees were aboard the train and
sorting out the mail during the journey
picking up new mail bags and dropping
off others on Route there were no other
passagers aboard just a few dozen postal
workers plus the railway engine driver
Jack Mills and this fireman Dave Whitby
this particular train was cloy known as
the up special and typically it only
carried around £300,000 in cash but this
time as it was coming off a bank holiday
weekend where you know a lot of Britains
like to celebrate get pissed there was a
lot more money on board than usual the
information from the olster had proven
solid around 3:00 a.m. the train was
reaching Sear's Crossing in Booking
Shire a few miles from the town of
Leighton Buzzard that is where Mills
spotted an Amber signal light ahead
warning him to proceed with caution a
little further ahead there was a red
light so the engine driver brought his
train to a halt what he did did not know
is that the green light was actually on
and working just fine the robbers simply
obscured it by placing a glove over it
they then powered the other signal
Lights by rigging them up to some
batteries and the driver fell for it
hook line and sinker it's not stupid if
it works the train had no means of
communication with the outside world
because 80s and this was an unplanned
stop so the 26-year-old fireman David
Whitby got out of the engine and walked
to the Trackside telephone to call and
see what all the Hub up was it's
unlikely that he would have been able to
reach anyone though since the criminals
did have the foresight to cut the Wes
but before he could inform Mills of this
new revelation he was approached and
pushed to the ground by one of the
robbers wearing a ski mask the man
lunged at Whitby and warned him that he
would kill him if he tried to shout or
do anything else Reckless wisely the
young fireman opts to remain quiet as a
church mouse and obey the orders given
to him after all it wasn't his money
they were stealing yeah I still think
that's my favorite line from The Dark
Knight where they walk in with shotguns
and just like it's not your money we're
stealing it's the banks it's all insured
don't be a hero and it's like yeah it's
not my money and then there's the guy
the shotgun comes out and just starts
blasting it's like hell
yeah what an opening what a movie while
one Robber restrained Whitby a couple of
others made their way into the engine
and overpowered the middle-aged Mills by
the time Whitby was brought into the cab
where he was faced against the wall and
had his hands tie behind on his back
there was about half a dozen robbers
inside the locomotive and Jack Mills was
lying on the ground in a pool of his own
blood after receiving a serious wallup
to the nogin from one of them once he
started to come to he and Whitby were
tied together taken down to the tracks
and placed on the ground on the right in
Bank while all this was happening the
workers were still inside sorting the
mail blissfully unaware that anything
had gone wrong quite conveniently the
hvp coaches with all the important and
valuable packages were placed right
behind the engine which meant the
robbers could simply decouple the other
carriages and drive off with just the
engine and the hvp compartments this was
indeed what they intended to do up until
this point their plan had worked pretty
much like clockwork and they really came
off like a team of Pros straight out of
an oceans 11s film this was the moment
when the high start to Veer off more
into carry on territory the guy that
Ronnie BS had hired to drive the train
couldn't drive the train old stanner
gate as he was referred to although his
true identity has never been revealed
had only experience with shunting
locomotives and knew nothing about the
fancy diesel electric locomotive that
powered the up special both he and bigs
proved to be pretty useless so they were
relegated to carrying M backs the other
robbers were then put in the awkward
position of having to get out of the
train to retrieve the half-conscious
Jack Mills and ask him quite nicely to
drive the locomotive and two coaches
further down the track to bedo bridge
where the gang had parked their getaway
vehicles and that must have been an
awkward conversation like all right mate
yeah yeah you see we you know we knock
your up inside the swed but you all
right to drive this motor down to um the
bridge yeah that all right cool we we
good right go all right let's go for
anyone wondering yes that's how I really
talk when I'm not in videos once this
was done some of the robbers forc their
way into the hvp coaches which didn't
prove to be too difficult like they were
just postal workers and there were no
guards or policeman present like what
were they really going to do and to
their credit they did try to prevent the
robbers getting in by like stacking bags
of mail against the door but this was
hardly an impenetrable barrier the chief
soter Frank duur and the post office
inspector Thomas Kent both got a few
smacks about the head for trying to play
Hero while the other four just obeyed
instructions and lay on the floor Mills
and Whitby were also brought into the
carriage as well and all eight people
sat in time out while the robbers formed
a human chain to load the 120 mailbags
into their truck half an hour later the
deed was done the criminals got into
their truck and two Land Rovers and
drove off into the
[Music]
night The Heist was finished but now
came the really tricky part getting away
with it so the gang didn't exactly have
to drive far because months earlier they
rented a rundown old farmhouse named
leather slate Farm in Oakley
buckinghamshire with the help of the
Crooked clerk Brian Fields it was
located only about 25 M away from the
scene of the crime this Farmhouse had
plenty of supplies in the men just plan
to lay low for a while enjoy some
quality time together and fantasize
about what they were going to do with
their illg Gams in regards to the money
when it was all divided up between the
men it amounted to about $150,000 a
piece for each man plus a few smaller 20
to 40,000 shares for various Associates
or drinks as they like to call them
unfortunately their plans were scuppered
by mistake number two earlier when they
were getting ready to leave the trains
one of the robbers turn to the eight
people inside the coach and warned them
to sit quietly and not do anything for
30 minutes or else or else what exactly
it's not like they' to make good on that
threat because it's one of those things
that always happens in like Heist moves
like everyone lay on the floor and count
to a 100 it's like well you're not going
to wait around are you obviously he
going to run straight away you know and
I know that the instant I stop hearing
your shoes hit the ground I'm going to
get up and call the police and it's
likely the robber who issued this
warning never really thought twice about
it but it did end up giving the police a
key bit of information that being that
the getaway location must be within a 30
30-minute Drive of where the train had
stopped and for the Curious leather
Slade Farm did indeed fall within that
30-minute radius speaking of the police
the postal workers didn't exactly just
lie there on the floor once the
criminals were well and truly gone they
got up and alerted the local authorities
or the rosers and then called booking
Hamshire County police and Scotland Yard
by the time the robbers had reached the
farm they were already hearing the news
of their daring Heist being broadcast
over Police radios a few hours later
Scotland yard's major crime unit
popularly known as the flying Squad was
on the case led by detective Sergeant
Jack slipper as a small wood yeah I'm
not going to make fun of that name I
don't feel like I have the right to do
so so there wasn't much in the way of
evidence all the robbers wore masks so
nobody really got a good look at them
and they knew not to call each other by
their first names Whit be the fireman
was the only one who really had any
extra information as he saw the
criminals make their getaway in an army
truck and a Land Rover although it was
more Instinct than had evidence it was
also the offhand 30-minute Remar that
gave the investigators their best lead
they mapped out a 30 M radius of the
bridge and plan to search all the
isolated buildings in that area pretty
smart meanwhile at the farm the gang was
in a celebratory mood they had a few
drinks lit cigars using pound notes and
even played Monopoly using real money to
make the whole game more interesting and
that sounds like how did they not just
end up shooting each other that sounds
like the worst idea ever however the
mood soon start to sour they weren't
feeling as confident as they once were
they probably figured out that the
police were searching all the remote
locations in the the area and it would
only be a matter of time before they
stumbled across leather slate Farm there
was also one thing these big city
criminals hadn't taken into account the
fact they weren't in London anymore they
were out in the countryside call it
friendly curiosity or call it nosy
snooping if you want but people in these
small communities tend to know
everything that's going on with
everybody else a gang of 15 or so men
rocking up in three trucks was not
exactly going to just pass unnoticed
even if the criminals had no intention
of popping down to a local pint for a
swift half neighboring Farmer John Maris
knew that leather Slade Farm had been
vacant for the last few months he had
not heard anything about new people
moving in so when he saw that someone
had taken up residence inside the
cottage it made him curious enough to go
in for a closer look I.E being a nosy
Twan The Farmhouse had heavy curtains
that the robbers had kept shut at all
times even during the daytime but while
this was supposed to be a precaution it
only made Maris all the more suspicious
because nobody else in the area did that
so even as he got closer to the building
he noticed that the Gage was locked and
that was a large truck parted in the
shed finally when he heard about the
heist and the authorities were looking
for a possible hideout in the area he
connected the dots and called the local
police and here's the thing it's like
I'm a big proponent of something I like
to call like just snitch rules and I
think like there should be like direct
financial compensation for just
snitching I know sometimes they offer
rewards for like catching criminals and
stuff but I want it for everything I
think any like crime that is punishable
by a fine if you snitch on that person
you should get percentage of that fine
let's you know get get let's get
everyone just snitching on everybody
else let's do it I I just want to report
people for like being on their phones in
cars and get 20 quid in the mail so I'm
so sick of nearly being hit by people on
their phones and cars as I try and cross
the road at a pelican Crossing so two
points worked in the robber's favor here
though first the police had received
hundreds of tips it took them a while
before they got to marises and second
the crooks had decided to move up their
schedule instead of spending the weekend
at The Farmhouse as they planned they
each took their share of the money and
left one by one on Thursday and Friday
by the time the police had arrived at
leather Slade everybody was already gone
but the hunt was just
beginning on August 13th 1963 just 5
days after The Great Train Robbery as it
was been called in the Press
investigators made their way to Lea
slave farm and immediately it became
evident that this was the place the
criminals had tried to lay low there
were mailbags and bank note rappers
everywhere as the bookham Shire
detective in charge of the case remarked
and I quote the whole place is one big
big clue like the robbers really had
halfast the whole getting rid of
evidence thing that you're supposed to
do when you want to you know get away
with a crime essentially this is because
they'd hired a cleaner to come in after
them and take care of all that according
to One account from one of the robbers
this person or persons we never found
out who they were was even supposed to
burn down the whole Farmhouse after
they' done the deed to you know
completely dispose of all possible
evidence however it seems that they got
cold feet when they saw the increased
police activity around the farm or maybe
they just took the money ran either way
the job did not get done Additionally
the robbers thought it might be a good
idea to just wear gloves the entire time
to avoid leaving any fingerprints but
they concluded that it was just too hot
to wear gloves and thought well screw it
we can just clean everything down after
the fact not to mention this whole
Farmhouse is going to be ashers in a few
days and to their credit they did try
and clean everything they touch but they
missed a few spots for example Prince
were found on a ketchup bottle and a
salt shaker and it's not a katch-up
bottle in the UK it's it's it's either
Tommy sauce tomato sauce or my personal
favorite a bottle of Tommy Kay it's not
ketchup that's that's an americanism no
they found on a bottle of Tommy K but
without a doubt the biggest break for
the police was the Monopoly board which
was completely covered in fingerprints
from nearly all the men involved and
isn't that how it always goes you always
forget to clean the Monopoly board all
the robbers were career criminals so
unsurprisingly Scotland Yard had their
prints on file and a week after the
heist they already had a few names to
look for but their first arrest came
even sooner than that so you know how in
heist movies like after they split the
cash someone always warns the rest of
the group don't be a bell end and go out
there and buy five cars it's me I got a
new car that's the most suspicious in
the world well it turns out that there
wasn't that one guy on this Cas there
was two guys Roger cordoy and William
bow they traveled to Bournemouth after
leaving the farm and immediately went on
a massive shopping spree buying three
cars and renting an apartment and a
lockup garage the landlord got
suspicious and told the cops who
arrested both men on August 15th after
discovering that they had used money
from the robbery to pay for the cars
later it was established that bowl
wasn't even one of the robbers just an
accomplice who helped cordoy and he
still got a very lengthy sentence
something which the police later
referred and admitted was a miscarriage
of Justice nine other members were
identified from fingerprints left on
that Monopoly board which included
Ronnie BS Charlie Wilson Buster Edwards
and the leader of the gang Bruce
Reynolds a few others like Gordon goody
were presumed to be involved since they
ran in the same circles one by one they
all start to fall and only two or three
members it's not clear how many were
never identified for certain and all
escaped repercussions by the time the
trial had started in January 1964 12 of
the robbers were in custody and they all
protested their innocence except for
cordoy who admitted his guilt there's
always one this did little to impress
judge Edmund Davies who reasoned that
and I quote to deal with this case
leniently would be a positively evil
thing he dished out 30-year sentences
like they were candy or sweets sweets
here in the UK it's not candy So Pro tip
we don't have candy we have sweets and
it's worth noting that these 30e
sentences were kind of out of the
ordinary for this judge because just the
previous year he' reduced another
robbers terms from 15 to 10 years
because he thought the original sentence
was excessive and that robbery had
resulted in a death in all the robbers
and their accomplices got a combined 307
years in prison though none of them
actually served their full sentences it
was pretty clear that The Great Train
Robbery which been the biggest story in
the country for over the previous six
months greatly divided public opinion
and caused a stir in everyone even those
who were supposed to be impartial the
criminals have become minor celebrities
in their own right and they had their
fans who campaigned for leniency even
author gram green wrote and I quote am I
one of a minority in feeling admiration
for the skill and courage Behind The
Great Train Robbery more important am I
in a minority in being shocked by the
savagery in the sentences reminder they
caved a guy skulling with a bat and I
really don't know how to just process a
guy being like am I the only one to
appreciate the skill and courage
displayed by these men who viciously
beat an unarmed man half to death with a
bat what the so-called Mastermind Bruce
Reynolds managed to evade the
authorities for 5 years he moved abroad
with his family first to Mexico then to
Canada and finally to France eventually
he hoped that the heat had die down
enough that he could move back to
England and you know away from France
and he lived under a fake identity in
talking Reynolds was of course wrong he
was identified and arrested soon after
and sent to prison into a maximum
security unit that being specifically
Built For The Train Robbers in Durham he
was released on parole in 1978 and made
good use of the notoriety he built up
for himself by making sporadic media
appearances writing autobiography and
even acting as a movie consultant on
heist movies if you're wondering why it
was deemed necessary for the robbers to
have their own special prison unit is
because of Charlie Wilson and Ronnie BS
who both escaped while incarcerated
Wilson even had a three-man team bust
him out and then moved to Canada where
he spent four years before being tracked
down and arrested like Reynolds he
stayed in prison till 1978 however
unlike Reynolds he just couldn't stop
committing crimes and this eventually
got him shot in the head on the doorstep
of his own home in 1990 his killer was
never apprehended clearly a better
Criminal than he was Ronnie bigs
meanwhile became inarguably the most
famous member of The Heist gang not for
his role in the robbery but for his
quite colorful life after it so in 1965
he escaped wesworth prison by scaling
the wall with a rope ladder and jumping
on top of a getaway van he then spent
some time in France Spain and even
Australia before settling in Brazil
where he fathered a son eventually the
British police did manage to track him
down but there was really nothing they
could do the two countries had no
extradition treaty and even if they did
the fact that he had a Brazilian son
gave him virtually complete immunity
from being extradited for his crimes
eventually in 2001 Ronny bigs returned
to England voluntarily according to his
son this is because he wanted to and I
quote walk into a pub as an Englishman
and buy a pint of bitter what a legend
he was arrested of course and sent to
prison until 2009 when he released on
compassionate ground his arrival was
Major news in all the country's
newspapers I I remember this happening
when I was a kid particularly the
Tabloid which were more than happy to
make some more money for old rope it
quickly became evident that even after
almost half a century the public was
still fascinated with this old tale of
Daring ingenious and at times blundering
Heist known as The Great Train Robbery
and I would have like had a pain for
recording this one this is my first
recording session of the day so coffee
it is so yes I hope everyone out there
enjoyed this video I certainly enjoyed
recording it and shout outs to um Ru
Alexander the script writer for this one
for their work check out um their
socials below if they have been provided
and yeah if you're a fan of this video
this format um like comment subscribe
all that good stuff if you have any
other you know daring tales and
escapades you'd like us to cover on
biographics like you know let us know in
the comments and maybe a member of our
writing team will get right around to
writing about it and then I'll get
around to you know ruining it in a video
speaking of which I I'm hoping that my
presentation style for my my earlier
videos has improved somewhat I feel like
it has but you know let us know in the
comments if any improvements I could
make to either my presentation my
hosting or just the look of videos
itself I greatly appreciate um the
opportunity top 10 biographics and
Geographics have afforded Me by stepping
in as the interim host in this um period
of transition and I hope that everybody
out there has the day they deserve
cheers